D
WORLD SECURITY.
JOINING US NOW FORMER
AMBASSADOR TO THE U.N.,
FORMER GOVERNOR OF GREAT
STATE OF SOUTH CAROLINA,
AUTHOR OF THE NEW BOOK "IF
YOU WANT SOMETHING DONE."
AMBASSADOR NIKKI HALEY THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US, WHAT DO
YOU MAKE OF WHAT PUTIN IS
SAYING AND DOING?
I THINK PUTIN IS FEELING
DESPERATE, I THINK YOU SEE
IT IS -- HE HIT A LOW POINT
HE GETS DRONES FROM IRAN AND
ROCKETS FROM NORTH KOREA, HE
LOST THE FAITH OF HIS
MILITARY AND CONFIDENCE OF
HIS PEOPLE.
AND I THINK HE IS TRYING TO
BUY TIME TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
HE WILL DO.
WHAT WE HAVE TO DO IS MAKE
SURE WHEN WE GOES AND ADDS
THE NUCLEAR THREATS WE DON'T
GO RUNNING FOR THE HILLS AND
KEEP OUR FOOT ON THE GAS.
HE SAID IF HE TOOK UKRAINE
THAT POLAND AND THE BALTICS
WERE NEXT, WE DON'T NEED TO
BE GIVING UKRAINE BLANK
CHECKS BUT TO WORK WITH
NATO, SO THEY HAVE THE
EQUIPMENT TO DEFEND
THEMSELVES AND FINISH THE
DEAL, IF THEY CONTINUE AND
WIN THIS WAR, IT WILL SEND A
MESSAGE TO IRAN, NORTH KOREA
AND CHINA.
TREY: YOU MENTIONED NORTH
KOREA.
THEY SEEM TO BE ACTING LIKE
A CHILD, MISBEHAVING, TRYING
TO GET ATTENTION.
OPTIONS ARE IGNORE THEM AND
HOPE THEY GO AWAY.
OR IS THERE SOMETHING THAT
CAN BE DONE THAT IS NOT
BEING DONE?
>> WHEN I WAS AT UNITED
NATIONS THEY WERE TESTING
BALLISTIC MISSILES EVERY
OTHER WEEKEND, I PASSED THE
LARGEST SANCTIONS IN A
GENERATION AGAINST NORTH
KOREA AND I WAS ABLE TO GET
THE WORLD TO GO ALONG WITH
US AT THE TIME.
NORTH KOREA SENSE --
WEAKNESS IN AMERICA, THEY
ARE TRYING TO SEE IF THEY
CAN SCARE US INTO LIFTING
THOSE SANCTIONS WE SHOULD
NOT, ANY AMOUNT THAT GOES TO
NORTH KOREA GOES TO FEED
THEIR NUCLEAR
PROGRAM NOT THEIR PEOPLE.
THERE IS NOT OKAY, WE NEED
TO, STAY ON COURSE, THEY
WANT TO SEE IF THEY CAN
SCARE US THE SAME WAY THAT
PUTIN IS TRYING TO DO IT AND
THE IIA TOLDAS
IN IRAN ARE TRYING, YOU HAVE
TIE RAPTS COMING OUT TO SEE
IF THEY CAN RUN --
TYRANTS.
>> WE'RE SPANNING THE GLOBE.
HOW ABOUT SAUDI ARABIA, WHAT
DO YOU MAKE OF OUR CURRENT
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
SAUDIS, DOES IT NEED TO BE
REPAIRED?
IF SO, HOW.
>> BIDEN RUINED ST.
IT.
WE HAD A GOOD RELATIONSHIP
WITH SAUDI ARABIA UNTIL THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION CAME
IN, HE IS SHOCKED THEY CUT
PRODUCTION.
I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU COULD
BE SHOCKED WHEN YOU ASKED
FOR THE WORLD TO CONSIDER
THE CROWN PRINCE AN
INTERNATIONAL PARIAH.
HE IS IN HIS
30s HEALTH OUT LAST EVERY
LEADER.
AND BIDEN IS FALLING ALL
OVER HIMSELF TO GET BACK
FROM THE IRAN DEAL.
NONE OF THE ARAB COUNTRIES
WANTED.
FOR BIDEN SAY HE WILL GET
THEM BACK FOR THAT, THE BEST
WAY TO GET BACK IS TO BECOME
ENERGY INDEPENDENT.
GOING PICKING A FIGHT
WITH SAUDI ARABIA IS NOT
HELPFUL TO ANYONE.
AND IDEA HE RATHER THAN
GOING WITH CLEAN ENERGY LIKE
WE HAVE HERE IN UNITED
STATES, FACT HE WANTS DIRTY
OIL FROM VENEZUELA AND IRAN
MAKES US LOOK RIDICULOUS IN
THE EYES OF THE WORLD.
TREY: AMBASSADOR, I'M TRYING
TO REMEMBER SOMEONE FAMOUS
SAID, IF YOU WANT SOMETHING
DONE, GET A WOMAN DO IT.
IT MIGHT HAVE BEEN YOU, THE
FORMER GOVERNOR OF GREAT
STATE OF SOUTH CAROLINA,
THAT IS THE TITLE OF YOUR
BOOK.
ONLY ONE JOB LEFT FOR YOU.
YOU HAVE DONE EVERYTHING BUT
ONE JOB.
WHAT LEAD YOU TO WRITE THE
BOOK WHAT DOES FUTURE
HOLD FOR GOVERNOR NIKKI
HALEY.
>> THE QUOTE IS FROM
MARGARET THATCHER.
THE PUBLISHER ASKED ME TO
WRITE THIS BOOK.
AND AS PARENTS WE SHOULD TRY
TO MAKE SURE OUR GIRLS
UNDERSTAND WE'RE NOT VICTIMS
WE DON'T NEED QUOTAS, IF WE
WORK HARD AND PROVE WE
DESERVE TO BE IN THE ROOM
GREAT THINGS HAPPEN.
PROFILES OF WOMEN WHO WERE
ORDINARY BECAME EXTRA IN
EXTRAORDINARY.
I HOPE IT MOTIVATES WOMEN TO
GO FORWARD, RIGHT NOW IF WE
DON'T WIN IN NOVEMBER, THERE
IS NO 2024, WE HAVE ENDORSED
60 CANDIDATES AND RAISED
OVER 6 MILLION DOLLARS IN
THEIR CAMPAIGN ACCOUNTS WE
HOPE FOR A FUN
NOVEMBER.
THIS SHOULD IT WORK, AFTER
JANUARY WHOLE MAKE A
DECISION.
TREY: AMBASSADOR NIKKI
HALEY, YOU ARE RIGHT, YOU
BEAT A CROWDED FIELD FOR
GOVERNORSHIP.
YOU SURPRISED THEM ALL.
I WILL CHECK IN WITH YOU
AFTER NOVEMBER TO SEE WHAT
THE FUTURE HOLDS, THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US O